Welcome back everyone it;s Charlie this is
going to be my new Thor 4 video for a
cosmic Thor we have a bunch of beta ray
bill Easter eggs we found in the
previous Marvel movies including
Avengers end games that's right there's
even some beta ray bill Easter eggs in
endgame so we'll break all those scenes
down and the most powerful versions of
Thor in the MCU and in the comics if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite version of Thor on the
video from the comics or from the movies
so we'll start with all the cosmic Thor
most powerful versions of Thor then I'll
talk about the beta ray bill scenes in
Avengers endgame in the other Marvel
movies we've gotten a bunch of teasers
for Thor 4 love and thunder so far we
know a little bit about what's going on
with Christian Bale's villain I know
everyone wants him to be gore the god
butcher right now he's just the top tier
choice but there are a number of other
big cosmic villains that he could be
playing but starting with number 5
Thor between the events of Thor the dark
world in Avengers age of Ultron because
it's implied during that period he was
wearing his special magic belt the
Megane yard which doubles his strength
the belt that was referenced by happy
when he was packing up the rest of the
things in the Avengers Tower all the
different belongings because they just
sold it to a quote-unquote mystery buyer
that we still don't quite know who it is
as a spider-man far from home I got a
lot of questions when thor ragnarok and
infinity war and end game came out why
wouldn't thor wear that magic belt to
double his strength when he was fighting
all these different battles usually
that's just because you have different
writers and directors working on the
movies and they have different ideas
about the journey that they want to take
the character on like Thor has an arc
during infinity war and Avengers endgame
he's dealing with the grief and loss of
his people the loss of Loki so the
Russos didn't give him that belt just
because it would have made him super
opie and subverted some of that arc at
the beginning of the movie till he
eventually got Stormbreaker number 4
Thor from Thor Ragnarok after he'd
realized the true source of his power
the hammer is just there to channel your
power the natural ability that you have
as a god one of the things they did with
this movie is get into more of the
mythology of Thor in the MCU and treat
him more like an actual god unless just
like an alien from another planet you
had to think of the odinforce the Thor
force is more this innate biological
feel that they generate because they're
so deeply tied to magic in the MCU
but the ambiguous way that they explain
it they kind of make him seem like he is
an actual deity within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and if you were
confused there is an actual God capital
G of the Marvel Comics he's called the
one above all I don't know if they're
ever going to get into that in the
movies
probably not but they might imply that
there's some higher sentence above
eternity number three is Thor during
Avengers infinity war after he'd
obtained Stormbreaker so you have a
low-level god tier Thor who just
recognized where his true strength lies
learned about the Thor force and learned
how to use it
but now he has gained Stormbreaker the
king's weapon which actually requires
the strength of a king someone like Thor
with his power to be able to wield it
correctly and use all of its abilities
the reason why Stormbreaker is so much
more powerful than Mjolnir is because as
they say during Thor Ragnarok the hammer
was really just there to help Thor
channel his power before he truly knew
how it worked then there's all the other
abilities that Stormbreaker gives him
the ability to open a Bifrost
at will the reason why he wasn't as
powerful during endgame is just because
he'd lost his confidence he didn't lose
the Thor force so he still had the same
level of abilities available to him he
just wasn't quite firing on all
cylinders even though it was really cool
to see him dual wield Mjolnir and storm
breaker
it's killing properly this time
- next most powerful is cosmic Thor now
cosmic Thor to the MCU will obviously be
different from cosmic Thor of the comics
both very cool concepts the brand-new
version of cosmic Thor that just debuted
in the comics is actually a version that
Galactus gives the power cosmic - making
him his Herald so that they can team up
to stop this black winter sentient star
plague bringing it back around to the
movies and what's happening after the
events of Avengers endgame cosmic Thor
is a version of Thor who's basically
dealing with God Tyr problems around the
universe and no longer has time or
doesn't really want to be King Thor
anymore so he kind of passes on his
duties that's basically what he does at
the end of Avengers endgame when he
passes the title of king of Asgard two
Valkyries so that she can deal with the
day-to-day stuff and he can go deal with
big cosmic problems they're very vague
about what he's going to be doing with
the as guardians of the galaxy and even
though they've confirmed
thank you very much Vin Diesel that
there will be crossover between Thor
inside guardians of the galaxy three and
the Guardians will appear during Thor
for love and thunder the part of the
journey of every Thor story regardless
of whose movie he appears in whether
it's the guardians or Avengers infinity
war or Thor 4 love and thunder to make
a Dragonball Z or Dragon Ball super Goku
reference is that it's all about Thor
getting his ass handed to him by a
villain in Thor 4 it's going to be
Christian Bale's villain character then
rallying finding an even deeper well of
power within himself to achieve new
heights of strength in defeating that
villain so the next tier up for MCU Thor
is basically a cosmic version of Thor
but it's not going to be like the power
cosmic version from the comics recently
just because we don't quite have
Galactus yet and for those of you
wanting to see Silver Surfer in the MCU
remember he actually spent a lot of time
in the classic Thor comics so I am
hoping that at some point in the future
we see a Silver Surfer Thor crossover
everyone post your Marvel Point Break
memes on the video but the crazy thing
is is that cosmic Thor isn't even the
most powerful version of Thor
the most powerful version is still one
rune King Thor from The Avengers
disassembled Arab Marvel Comics this is
a version of Thor who was able to obtain
the Odin for
but a much more powerful version of the
odinforce than Odin was ever able to tap
into the reason why he's called rune
King Thor is because there's he's
Asgardian runes that allow him to tap
into a much deeper well of magic in
abilities give him God Tyr power way
beyond what Oh de Nueva obtained he
eventually becomes one with the universe
itself he's not Nitin so obviously
that's not a version we're probably
going to see in the movies but there was
kind of an Easter Egg for rune King Thor
during Thor Ragnarok there was a deleted
scene from the infinity Saga box set
were Odin literally lays hands on him
and passes the odinforce to him that
later in the movie he recognizes his own
power and is able to tap into it so it
sounds like for a brief period they were
thinking about doing a version of rune
King Thor for that movie but moving into
all the new beta ray bill for for love
and thunder Easter eggs we actually just
found some more Easter eggs in the other
recent Marvel movies there been some
beta ray bill deleted scenes in earlier
Marvel movies Kevin Feige just said
they're saving the character for a big
upcoming story recently Marvel just
posted the screenplay for Avengers
endgame there were obviously a ton of
deleted scenes and moments that didn't
make it into the final cut of the movie
but one of them is actually a big beta
ray bill Easter Egg when the Avengers go
back in time to get all the different
Infinity stones you go to the 2014 when
they're trying to steal the Power Stone
during this you see a bunch of scenes
with Gamora nebula and Thanos of 2014
culling half the population of an alien
planet talking to each other it's
revealed in the screenplay that this
planet is actually Korbin the home of
the korbinites
in the home of beta ray bill now this
character that they're fighting is not
beta ray bill this is just another
korbinite wearing a giant suit of armor
the korbinites themselves don't look
like beta ray bill the reason why beta
ray bill looks like this is because his
people genetically modified him to
become even more powerful and defend
them from anybody that's thought to do
them harm think about the timeline of
this - this is happening at 2014 before
the events of thor ragnarok
and during thor ragnarok we found out
that beta ray bill really was a
character they actually deleted some of
his scenes early on the reason why his
head shows up on the grandmasters Tower
is because he was going to be one of the
members of the contest of Champions
before the hook came along so it's
implied that the Hulk defeated him when
he
came to Sekar so it's implied that beta
ray bill had to leave the planet or flee
when Thanos killed half of the people in
exile and that's how he wound up in the
contest of Champions the really cool
connection to Thor 4 love and thunder
beta ray bill and Thor is that in the
comics when they first met each other
they actually fought in the movies right
now for still wields storm breaker but
in the comics that's the name of beta
ray Bill's hammer his hammer looks a
little bit different he was given that
hammer by Odin after he defeated Thor in
combat
imagine how much beta ray bill would
hate Thor for not protecting his people
and knowing that he was supposed to
become King after Odin and that the
Avengers gained the ability to time
travel and Thor didn't use that to help
the korbinites in beta ray bills people
so early prediction that's one reason
for them to fight each other beta ray
bill would be pissed that the Asgardians
we're not helping them protecting them
the way they were supposed to the other
funny connection to the movies too you
have to remember is that during 2014
when beta ray bills home planet is busy
being cold by Thanos here is that it was
actually while Loki was pretending to be
Odin also not really being King mostly
just chilling out watching plays of
himself but everyone let me know in the
comments what's your favorite version of
Thor and who do you want to play beta
ray bill in the MCU hopefully they'll
keep him around and he can join a future
Guardians team even if they don't do
more Guardians films after guardians of
the galaxy 3 I will do more Guardians 3
videos as we get more information about
that movie but they're not going to
start filming it for a while I've got a
bunch of big Marvel videos coming up so
as long as you have alerts enabled you
should see those videos when I post them
there's a special Marvel project that I
just announced to I'll link that video
at the end of this everyone click here
for my Thor 4 Christian Bale video and
click here for that big announcement
about the Marvel rewatch project thank
you so much for watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!